It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Every year, there are more than 2.8 million traumatic brain injuries in the U.S. The risks of brain injury among young athletes, pro football players, and members of the military have made headlines in recent years. But other populations are at increased risk as well, including people in the criminal justice system and domestic violence survivors. Today we're going to talk to a neuropsychologist about what researchers are learning
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。美国每年有超过 280 万例创伤性脑损伤。近年来，年轻运动员、职业橄榄球运动员和军人面临的脑损伤风险已成为头条新闻。但其他群体也面临着日益增加的风险，包括司法系统中的人员和家庭暴力幸存者。今天，我们将与一位神经心理学家探讨研究人员在了解
about the prevalence of brain injury and how, best to prevent and treat it. So what constitutes a traumatic brain injury? How common are TBIs? What happens to the brain when you get a concussion? What should we be doing to help protect athletes from brain injuries from youth sports to professional leagues? What effective therapies do we have to help people recover from TBI and what could we be doing to mitigate the harms of brain injury in often overlooked populations such as domestic violence survivors and prison inmates. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
脑损伤的普遍性以及如何最好地预防和治疗它方面有哪些发现。那么，什么是创伤性脑损伤？脑损伤有多常见？当你脑震荡时，大脑会发生什么？为了保护运动员免受从青少年体育到职业联赛的脑损伤，我们应该做些什么？我们有哪些有效的疗法来帮助人们从脑损伤中恢复？我们又能做些什么来减轻那些常被忽视的群体（如家庭暴力幸存者和监狱囚犯）所受到的脑损伤伤害？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Kim Gorgens, a professor of psychology at the University of Denver, where she teaches psychophysiology, clinical neuropsychology, and the psychology of criminal behavior. She has worked for decades studying and treating brain injuries in populations, including youth athletes, prison inmates, and survivors of domestic violence. In addition to her research, clinical work, and teaching, she's an advocate for TBI awareness and helped draft a 2020 concussion law in Colorado. She also lectures and speaks frequently to the media about brain injury, and her work has been featured in outlets including U.S. News, Newsweek, and Scientific American.
我是 Kim Mills。今天的嘉宾是丹佛大学心理学教授 Kim Gorgens 博士，她在那里教授心理生理学、临床神经心理学和犯罪行为心理学。几十年来，她一直致力于研究和治疗包括青少年运动员、监狱囚犯和家庭暴力幸存者在内的各类人群的脑损伤。除了研究、临床工作和教学外，她还是脑损伤意识的倡导者，并协助起草了科罗拉多州 2020 年的脑震荡法案。她还经常在媒体上就脑损伤问题发表演讲，她的工作曾被《美国新闻与世界报道》、《新闻周刊》和《科学美国人》等媒体报道。
Dr. Gorgans, thank you for joining me today. Kim, it's such a pleasure. Thank you so much for having me. I think this is the highlight of the year for me. Wow, that's saying a lot. It really is. I love that it's the Kim and Kim show. Oh, perfect. Yeah, we work that out. So let's start with a fundamental question, which is, what is a traumatic brain injury, how do doctors know when somebody has had a TBI and not just a knock on the head? This is a great question, and there's really two component parts to the question as you, just asked it. A brain injury is any insult to the brain, and that means it includes the whole of the universe of traumatic brain injuries. Those are injuries that are caused by the application of some
Gorgens 博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。Kim，非常荣幸。非常感谢邀请我。我觉得这是我今年最精彩的时刻。哇，这评价很高啊。确实如此。我喜欢这是“Kim 和 Kim”的节目。哦，太完美了。是的，我们商量好了。那么，让我们从一个基本问题开始：什么是创伤性脑损伤？医生是如何判断某人是患有脑损伤，而不仅仅是头部受到撞击呢？这是一个很好的问题，正如你刚才所问的，这个问题实际上包含两个部分。脑损伤是对大脑的任何损伤，这意味着它涵盖了创伤性脑损伤的整个范畴。这些损伤是由施加在头部的某种
external force or blow to the head. We also talk a lot more recently about blast injuries, so a hyper-pressurized wave of air. It also includes all the ways the brain can be damaged by being deprived of oxygen. We call those anoxic brain injuries, as is the case strangulation, near-lethal overdose with synthetic opiates. The second part of your question, though, is a much more nuanced one, which is, and how do doctors know when you have one? And the reality is we don't have great gold standard diagnostic tests for brain injury, particularly for mild brain injury. At this point, there's one new FDA-approved test, an Abbott test, that is available in some settings, only in emergency rooms, only in settings with laboratories that are designed to run this test.
外部力量或打击引起的。最近我们谈论更多的是爆炸伤，即高压空气波造成的伤害。它还包括大脑因缺氧而受损的所有方式。我们称之为缺氧性脑损伤，例如勒颈、合成阿片类药物过量导致的近乎致命的情况。然而，你问题的第二部分要微妙得多，那就是：医生怎么知道你是否患有脑损伤？现实情况是，我们目前还没有针对脑损伤（尤其是轻度脑损伤）的黄金标准诊断测试。目前，有一种新的 FDA 批准的测试，即雅培测试，仅在某些环境（如急诊室）和设有专门实验室的机构中可用。
So a lot of us in the research space, it's like a gold rush to find some easy, guard, standard way of identifying someone who's had a brain injury so that we can say to that person, here's how you need to be careful as you recover from brain injury. In the short term, though, what we're left with is subjective complaints of the person who is injured. And of course, that opens the door for other ways that we minimize symptoms, where the culture of whatever we're doing at the time encourages us to walk it off, for example, or where it might be too dangerous to disclose having a brain injury in the case of interpersonal violence. And it makes it really difficult for people who sustain brain injury to feel the validation of the health care system,
因此，我们许多研究人员都在争分夺秒地寻找一种简单、标准的识别方法，以便我们能告诉患者，在脑损伤恢复期间需要注意什么。然而，在短期内，我们只能依赖受伤者的主观陈述。当然，这为我们淡化症状提供了空间，比如在某些文化中，我们被鼓励“忍一忍就好”，或者在人际暴力的情况下，披露脑损伤可能过于危险。这使得遭受脑损伤的人很难从医疗系统中获得认可，
because there isn't a way to say, well, indeed, you've had a brain injury. So, diagnostically, any alteration of consciousness is a brain injury. So if you struck your head, or if you were strangled to unconsciousness, that is a mild brain injury. And determining how long that loss of consciousness was, it may be a more moderate or severe injury. But at a minimum, any alteration of consciousness is a mild traumatic brain injury. So what happens to the brain after a traumatic injury? I mean, is this something that you can sum up easily or are all brain injuries different? I love that you pointed that out.
因为没有一种方法能确切地说：“是的，你确实患有脑损伤。”因此，从诊断上讲，任何意识改变都属于脑损伤。所以，如果你撞到了头，或者被勒到失去知觉，那就是轻度脑损伤。而确定失去知觉的时间长短，可能意味着更中度或严重的损伤。但至少，任何意识改变都属于轻度创伤性脑损伤。那么，创伤后大脑会发生什么？我的意思是，这能简单概括吗？还是说所有的脑损伤都不一样？我很高兴你指出了这一点。
And in the brain injury world, Kim, you hear a lot of people, and clinicians especially, say, if you've seen one brain injury, you've seen one brain injury. So there is something very idiosyncratic about people's response. to brain injury, but uniformly, across the board, mild injuries are metabolic injuries. They're inflammatory injuries. So much like an injury anywhere in the body where the body's response, your immune system's response is to mount an inflammatory response, to mobilize tissue repair, and to heal the injury. That same phenomenon happens in the brain. We don't resolve inflammation in the brain as quickly, and neuroinflammation is associated with all manner of
在脑损伤领域，Kim，你会听到很多人，尤其是临床医生说：“如果你见过一例脑损伤，那你也就只见过那一例。”因此，人们对脑损伤的反应是非常独特的。但统一来说，轻度损伤都是代谢性损伤，也是炎症性损伤。就像身体任何部位的损伤一样，身体的反应（免疫系统的反应）是引发炎症反应，动员组织修复并治愈损伤。同样的现象也会在大脑中发生。我们大脑中炎症的消退速度没那么快，而神经炎症与各种
really negative effects, things like mood disturbance and behavioral discontrol and cognitive complaints. So the inflammatory aftermath of injury is where the really devastating effects come from. Now, Kit Sports are an area where we hear a lot about TBIs. Is the problem just football where young players sustain a lot of head injuries, or are there other sports that are also dangerous when it comes to TBIs? Such a great question, and I am so struck by how real this is for your listeners who maybe followed the story just this last weekend about the young player in Alabama who died after being taken to the emergency room from the field after sustaining a brain injury. And we don't know a lot about that case. And thankfully, there are few,
非常负面的影响有关，比如情绪障碍、行为失控和认知抱怨。因此，损伤后的炎症后果才是真正造成破坏性影响的根源。现在，体育运动是我们经常听到脑损伤的领域。问题仅仅在于橄榄球吗？年轻球员在那里遭受了大量头部损伤，还是说在脑损伤方面，其他运动也同样危险？这是一个很好的问题，我非常震惊于这对你的听众来说是多么真实，也许他们关注了上周末关于阿拉巴马州一名年轻球员的故事，他在赛场上遭受脑损伤后被送往急诊室，最终不幸去世。我们对那个案例了解不多。值得庆幸的是，
of them, less than 20 a year where a young athlete dies really on the field. But when we talk about youth sports, we talk a lot about the kinds of forces that the kids on the field are exposed to and the way their bodies are exposed to those forces and the way their brains are exposed to those forces. And your brain is pretty well designed. In fact, the most well-protected structure in the entire body is the central nervous system. And we're pretty well designed to withstand lateral impacts. So deceleration injuries where it's where your brain comes into contact with a stationary object and there is a lateral application of force.
每年在赛场上死亡的年轻运动员很少，不到 20 人。但当我们谈论青少年体育时，我们谈论的是赛场上的孩子们所承受的各种力量，以及他们的身体和大脑暴露在这些力量下的方式。其实，你的大脑设计得相当好。事实上，全身保护最严密的结构就是中枢神经系统。我们天生就能很好地承受侧向冲击。也就是减速损伤，即你的大脑与静止物体接触，并受到侧向力。
What the brain withstands very poorly is rotational force. And rotational force gets conferred where part of the body spins and that that force gets conferred to the brain. If you think about the whisk to kids playing youth sports, is not so much about lateral impact to their helmet, per se, but it's a way that they get checked in the body and that force gets translated to their head. The risk is especially high to younger athletes where, A, their neck musculature is not as strong as older, more robust athletes, and B, where the size discrepancy between players is much greater. Some kids have hit puberty, some kids haven't.
大脑非常难以承受的是旋转力。当身体的一部分旋转时，这种力就会传递给大脑。如果你想想孩子们参加青少年体育运动的风险，与其说是头盔受到的侧向冲击，不如说是他们身体受到撞击后，这种力传递到了头部。对于年轻运动员来说，风险尤其高，因为 A，他们的颈部肌肉不如年长、强壮的运动员发达；B，球员之间的体型差异要大得多。有些孩子已经进入青春期，有些还没有。
And so the way that those forces get conferred in the brains is rotational. And you see a lot more damage from that rotational force. Some kinds of sports happen to be lend themselves to more rotational injuries in the style of play. So that's body check and football and being tackled. It's hockey. But it's also importantly, in our concussion biomarker study, we realized that we were seeing a lot of divers with cognitive complaints. And we thought, well, gosh, we had to even include them. They were in our control group originally.
因此，这些力量传递到大脑的方式是旋转的。你会看到这种旋转力造成的损害要大得多。有些运动的比赛风格更容易导致旋转损伤。比如橄榄球中的身体冲撞和擒抱，还有冰球。但同样重要的是，在我们的脑震荡生物标志物研究中，我们意识到我们看到了很多有认知抱怨的跳水运动员。我们想，天哪，我们甚至不得不把他们包括进来。他们最初是在我们的对照组中。
But what we realized for divers was hitting their water from higher dive points actually was a lateral impact to the brain. So it isn't as simple as tackle sports, but it is most dangerously rotational. impact, but it's really, at the end of the day, any impact to the brain, the accumulation of those impacts over years and years is associated with poor outcomes. So that speaks to the question of protective equipment. I mean, like, you have protective equipment in sports like football, but you can't wear anything protective when you're diving. So is equipment an answer? Or, I mean, what is the answer for these other sports where it's really not so much that somebody has conked you on the head?
但我们意识到，对于跳水运动员来说，从高处跳入水中实际上是对大脑的侧向冲击。所以，这并不像擒抱类运动那么简单，但最危险的是旋转冲击。归根结底，任何对大脑的冲击，以及多年来这些冲击的积累，都与不良后果有关。这引出了防护装备的问题。我的意思是，橄榄球等运动有防护装备，但跳水时你无法佩戴任何防护装备。那么装备是答案吗？或者说，对于这些并不是因为有人敲你脑袋，而是因为你在进行这项运动而受伤的运动，答案是什么？
you're just doing the sport. Right. And we saw this when the NFL got rid of the checking rules or added checking rules so that you didn't have helmet-to-helmet-spearing. And youth football added heads-up style of play. This is about 15 years ago now. But kids were trained not to use their helmets in the course of play. So heads-up play.
没错。当 NFL 取消了冲撞规则或增加了冲撞规则，以防止头对头撞击时，我们就看到了这一点。青少年橄榄球增加了“抬头式”比赛风格。这大约是 15 年前的事了。但孩子们被训练在比赛中不要使用头盔。也就是抬头比赛。
And it reduced injuries. tremendously at the NFL level, that it had no impact whatsoever on the frequency of concussions in youth sports. So the answer isn't as simple as equipment or playing differently. Certainly, helmets have made a dramatic difference. And there is a whole argument to be made about helmets. And this conversation plays out at the NCAA level and high school level with women's lacrosse. And many of your viewers will know this, but women's lacrosse is not required to be helmeted. A lot of advocates pushed for it to be helmeted at the NCAA level. And a lot of opponents say that helmeting girls playing lacrosse would lead to an increased incidence of brain
这在 NFL 层面极大地减少了伤害，但对青少年体育中脑震荡的频率没有任何影响。所以答案并不像装备或改变比赛方式那么简单。当然，头盔带来了巨大的改变。关于头盔，还有很多争论。这种对话在 NCAA 和高中女子长曲棍球比赛中也在进行。很多听众可能知道，女子长曲棍球并不强制要求佩戴头盔。许多倡导者推动在 NCAA 层面强制佩戴头盔。而许多反对者则认为，让打长曲棍球的女孩佩戴头盔会导致脑损伤发生率增加，
injuries because the style of play would be different. And, you know, I appreciate that there are really two trains of thought there. There is no question that the injury is sustained by unhelmeted lacrosse players are more severe than they are by helmeted players. So on the clinical side, I'd argue that there's something to be wearing helmets. But it's also just about the sport itself. The risk is embedded in the style of play. Are there other steps that could be taken to protect players? For example, I was reading about the role of hydration in preventing TBI. What about strength training? And what kind of training to coaches need that maybe they're not getting right now?
因为比赛风格会发生变化。而且，我知道这两种观点都有道理。毫无疑问，未佩戴头盔的长曲棍球运动员所受的伤害比佩戴头盔的运动员更严重。所以从临床角度来看，我会说佩戴头盔是有意义的。但这也与运动本身有关。风险植根于比赛风格中。还有其他可以采取的保护球员的措施吗？例如，我读到过水分补充在预防脑损伤中的作用。力量训练呢？教练需要什么样的培训，而他们目前可能还没有得到？
It's so key. It's so key. That last point is such a good one. And with coaches, when we wrote our concussion legislation here in Colorado, we were the seventh state to do that. And the first state to, you know, include junior high school athletes. And our legislation required coaches, not only school coaches, but also intramural and pee-level coaches, community coaches, to be trained in how to recognize, identify, and manage concussions. So that's a really important point. So having an educated coach, and sometimes that's parents, sometimes that's someone who stepped in for a coach to cover, having that kind of education is key. Recognizing those injuries when they happen so that we can really quickly identify the needs of these kids is paramount. Otherwise, the rest of your question is, like, what can we do to better protect athletes? And it's strength training has great data. So it's
这非常关键。这非常关键。最后一点说得太好了。关于教练，当我们在这里科罗拉多州撰写脑震荡立法时，我们是第七个这样做的州。也是第一个将初中运动员纳入其中的州。我们的立法要求教练，不仅是学校教练，还包括校内和社区教练，接受如何识别、鉴定和管理脑震荡的培训。所以这是一个非常重要的点。因此，拥有一位受过教育的教练（有时是家长，有时是临时顶替的教练）是关键。在伤害发生时识别它们，以便我们能迅速确定这些孩子的需求，这是至关重要的。否则，你问题的其余部分，比如我们能做些什么来更好地保护运动员？力量训练有很好的数据支持。所以是
physical therapy. It's all kinds of strength training designed to be. that cervical spine, the musculature in the neck for kids, that's associated with fewer concussions as those kids are playing contact sports. Also training kids in things like flag football before they play contact football has some data to suggest that that yields fewer concussions. And there is just a really important point that I want to underline here, which is there was no question that the most healthy activity for kids is physical movement and exercise. It's everything about brain health. And sometimes this conversation gets mistaken for a conversation about we shouldn't have kids playing sports.
物理治疗。各种旨在增强颈椎和颈部肌肉的力量训练，对于参加接触性运动的孩子来说，与减少脑震荡有关。此外，在参加接触性橄榄球之前，对孩子进行腰旗橄榄球等训练，也有数据表明这能减少脑震荡。这里有一个非常重要的点我想强调，那就是毫无疑问，对孩子来说最健康的活动是身体运动和锻炼。这对大脑健康至关重要。有时这种对话会被误解为“我们不应该让孩子参加体育运动”。
And that, quite frankly, is absurd and would be the worst thing to ever happen. There is a way, however, to play context sports, in particular, in ways that potentially are safer. to ensure that we have the newest generation of protective equipment available to the kids, regardless of the funding of their school district or the kinds of resources available to those kids, for example, those two component parts we're still kind of striking out on. So if we could do better, we could meaningfully track a change in the frequency of these injuries and make a determination about where our efforts are best spent. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot.
坦率地说，这很荒谬，也将是发生过的最糟糕的事情。然而，确实有一种方式可以进行接触性运动，特别是以可能更安全的方式。确保我们为孩子们提供最新一代的防护装备，无论其学区的资金状况或资源如何，例如，这两个部分我们仍然做得不够。如果我们能做得更好，我们就能有意义地追踪这些伤害频率的变化，并确定我们的努力应该花在哪里。你的夏天从家得宝 (The Home Depot) 的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。
It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
是时候用 Next Grill 四炉头燃气烧烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 Home Depot.com/price-match。
What I hear you saying is we're not telling parents to pull your kids out of football or other contact sports, but is there an age at which it's appropriate to get started? I love this question. There is, you might know Robert Cantu, he and Anne McKee and a group of other researchers are at Boston University. They head up the Center for the Study of Traumatic Encephalopathy there. They have been very outspoken in this area, and I think some of their points are informed by certainly decades now of research to suggest that there is a cumulative risk to contact sport athletes, sustained not by a single injury, but by hundreds of thousands of sub-concussive blows over the course of a career.
我听到你说的是，我们并不是告诉家长让孩子退出橄榄球或其他接触性运动，但有没有一个合适的开始年龄？我喜欢这个问题。有的，你可能认识 Robert Cantu，他和 Anne McKee 以及其他研究人员在波士顿大学。他们负责那里的创伤性脑病研究中心。他们在这一领域非常直言不讳，我认为他们的一些观点无疑是基于几十年的研究，这些研究表明接触性运动运动员存在累积风险，这种风险不是由单一伤害造成的，而是由职业生涯中成千上万次亚脑震荡打击造成的。
And they're seeing those changes in athlete brains, even when those athletes do. in their 30s, for example. So their research suggests that there is something we don't know in its entirely about what happens at the time of brain injury, and particularly for people who sustain, again, these are hundreds, if not thousands, of brain injuries. Robert Cantu has made the point that the frequency with which people who go on to develop dementing disease played youth sports is much high. and his suggestion is based on what he sees in the pathology reports of brains that people donate
他们甚至在运动员 30 多岁时就能看到这些变化。因此，他们的研究表明，关于脑损伤发生时的情况，我们还有很多不完全了解的地方，特别是对于那些再次遭受成百上千次脑损伤的人来说。Robert Cantu 指出，那些后来患上痴呆症的人在青少年时期参加接触性运动的频率要高得多。
to their center for the study of brain-related disease, is that there isn't a reason for a junior high school and younger kids to play contact sports. So play flag football, play ultimate frisbee. And these all have some requisite risk to them, too. and kids can collide and sustain brain injuries, but it isn't the kind of brain injury that's embedded in the style of play. And also in high school, kids are stronger. The size differences between athletes are relatively minimized
他的建议是基于他在人们捐赠给他们中心研究脑相关疾病的病理报告中所看到的，即初中及以下的孩子没有理由参加接触性运动。所以去玩腰旗橄榄球，去玩极限飞盘。这些运动也有一定的风险，孩子们也可能碰撞并遭受脑损伤，但那不是植根于比赛风格中的那种脑损伤。而且在高中，孩子们更强壮了。运动员之间的体型差异相对较小，
where they've all more or less hit puberty. And so you minimize the impact of some of those differential rotational forces. So I tend to err on the Robert Cantu size, and say, like, is there a safer way to play a non-contact sport in junior high? And for the Pingui Pop-Whorner level, you bet. Like, do they go on to become as adept high school players? Yes, we don't have any reason or any piece of data to suggest that they're less
他们或多或少都进入了青春期。因此，你最大限度地减少了其中一些差异化旋转力的影响。所以我倾向于站在 Robert Cantu 这边，说：初中阶段有没有更安全的非接触性运动方式？对于青少年级别，当然有。他们以后会成为同样熟练的高中球员吗？是的，我们没有任何理由或数据表明，通过腰旗橄榄球成长起来的孩子在参加接触性橄榄球时表现得更差。
skillful playing contact football, having come up through the ranks playing flag football, for example. Let's change gears for a minute and talk about treatment. What happens then? What do you do with somebody where you've seen that this person has had a traumatic brain injury, multiple traumatic brain injuries? What do we do to mitigate the long-term and short-term effects of this damage? It's so key. And this is the point about identification of brain injury. And people think oftentimes it's just enough to know that someone had a brain injury. The reason you want to be able to identify a brain injury when it happens on the field. for example, is because you want to intervene and wrap that kid in a whole community of
让我们换个话题，谈谈治疗。那之后会发生什么？对于那些你已经确认患有创伤性脑损伤、多次创伤性脑损伤的人，你该怎么办？我们能做些什么来减轻这种损害的长期和短期影响？这非常关键。这就是识别脑损伤的意义所在。人们通常认为，知道某人患有脑损伤就足够了。你想要在赛场上识别出脑损伤的原因，例如，是因为你想要干预并用一个完整的支持社区来包围那个孩子，
support to promote recovery. And that means that they minimize the risk of sustaining another injury before they're fully recovered from that injury, that they are managing the symptoms of that injury optimally. So getting enough rest, but not too much rest, that they are able to return to the classroom on a schedule that works for them and that they can manage the need-related complaints. And they're prepared to manage the irritability that often comes with a brain injury and that they're informed and their parents are part of that team. And teachers are part of the return to learn plan and coaches are part of the return to play
以促进康复。这意味着他们要尽量减少在完全康复前再次受伤的风险，他们要以最佳方式管理损伤症状。所以要获得充足的休息，但不要休息过度，他们能够按照适合自己的时间表重返课堂，并且能够管理与需求相关的抱怨。他们准备好管理脑损伤常带来的易怒情绪，并且他们知情，他们的父母也是团队的一部分。老师是“重返学习”计划的一部分，教练是“重返比赛”计划的一部分。
plan. And with that approach, you see kids return to baseline where kids, kids, don't have this kind of 360 degree support, they would turn to play too quickly. The risk for even worse outcomes after sustaining another injury is much higher. And that's true for really mild injury. So sometimes kids get a really devastating set of consequences from what looks like a really mild injury that might not even have caught the attention of a coach or someone on the sideline, for example. So in a lot of cases, our research with youth sports suggests that we battle against a culture, a kind of warrior-like culture where the incentive is, and certainly
通过这种方法，你会看到孩子们恢复到基线水平。而那些没有这种 360 度支持的孩子，会过快地重返赛场。在再次受伤后出现更糟糕结果的风险要高得多。对于非常轻微的损伤也是如此。所以有时孩子们会因为看起来非常轻微的损伤而产生毁灭性的后果，这些损伤甚至可能没有引起教练或场边人员的注意。因此，在很多情况下，我们对青少年体育的研究表明，我们是在与一种文化作斗争，一种战士般的文化，其激励机制是——
this is true with college athletes who have a scholarship on the line, the incentive is to get athletes back out onto the field of play as quickly as possible. And we sometimes foreclose some of that recovery on their behalf. And depending on how many times we do that, the likelihood that they can get back up to wherever they were at baseline changes. So the treatment then amounts to just rest and vigilance. I mean, is there more than that that you can do to somebody who has had a traumatic brain injury? Yeah. It's all their anti-inflammatory intervention. It's stress management. It's getting optimal sleep. So not too much rest. We used to recommend like this is about rest and sleep as much as you. Well, first we used to recommend like, oh my God, don't let this injured kid fall asleep.
对于那些有奖学金压力的大学运动员来说尤其如此——激励机制是让运动员尽快回到赛场。我们有时会代表他们剥夺了部分康复机会。根据我们这样做的次数，他们回到基线水平的可能性就会发生变化。所以治疗就等于休息和警惕吗？我的意思是，对于患有创伤性脑损伤的人，除了这些还有更多能做的吗？是的。还有抗炎干预。是压力管理。是获得最佳睡眠。所以不要休息过度。我们过去建议，比如这完全取决于休息和睡眠。好吧，首先我们过去建议，天哪，别让这个受伤的孩子睡着。
Whatever. I remember that. Which is like impossible for families and really hard on kids. So that did not pan out. And then we said you should get as much rest as possible. And we realized like, oh, turns out that's not super helpful either. So this means it's seven and a half to nine hours of sleep in a 24 hour period. of time means being really vigilant about getting that sleep and all the other anti-inflammatory interventions. It's optimizing nutrition. It's using mindfulness. It's managing headache pain appropriately. So this is really, I think in the psychology world, this is where psychology can really shine. We treat inflammatory injuries better than anyone. Depression is an inflammatory disease. So we're really well prepared to meet these kids or anybody with an injury where they're at.
不管怎样。我记得那个。这对家庭来说是不可能的，对孩子来说也非常困难。所以这行不通。然后我们说你应该尽可能多地休息。我们意识到，哦，事实证明这也没什么帮助。所以这意味着在 24 小时内保证 7.5 到 9 小时的睡眠。意味着要非常警惕地保证睡眠以及所有其他抗炎干预措施。是优化营养。是使用正念。是适当地管理头痛。所以这真的，我认为在心理学界，这是心理学真正可以发光的地方。我们治疗炎症性损伤比任何人都好。抑郁症是一种炎症性疾病。所以我们非常准备好在这些孩子或任何受伤者所处的阶段去帮助他们。
But we tend to think of it as a kind of like, you're going to sleep this off and get better instead of like, we know from biomarker studies that the metabolic effects of even a single mild injury in kids take about three to six months to resolve. And that when those same kids sustain even another mild injury, it can take 12 months for those injury markers to resolve. So it can take longer than kids even feel symptomatic for it. So best that we get them as close to back to baseline as possible before we send them back into the classroom and back into the field of play. Now, my intro, I mentioned a couple of other populations that also experienced traumatic brain injury that maybe a lot of people don't think about. And I'm talking about survivors of domestic
但我们倾向于认为这就像“你睡一觉就会好起来”，而不是像我们从生物标志物研究中所知道的那样，即使是儿童的一次轻度损伤，其代谢影响也需要大约 3 到 6 个月才能消退。而当这些孩子再次遭受轻度损伤时，这些损伤标志物可能需要 12 个月才能消退。所以这可能比孩子们感到有症状的时间还要长。因此，最好在让他们重返课堂和赛场之前，让他们尽可能接近基线水平。现在，在我的介绍中，我提到了其他一些也经历过创伤性脑损伤的群体，很多人可能没有想到。我指的是家庭暴力幸存者。家庭暴力幸存者中脑损伤有多常见？你能告诉我们的听众你一直在与这个群体进行的工作吗？这非常重要。Kim，我喜欢你处理这个问题的方式，这是一个完美的过渡。听众们认为，我知道一些关于脑损伤的知识，因为我关注了最初由 NFL 球员妻子发起，后来由 NFL 球员及其退役球员联盟推动的对话。我们看过纪录片，我们对脑损伤、脑震荡（即轻度创伤性脑损伤）有相当稳健的公共讨论。人们可能没有意识到的是，在其他群体中，脑损伤比这更常见。所以，处于暴力关系中的人遭受脑损伤（特别是勒颈造成的创伤性和缺氧性脑损伤）的风险非常高。我只想和你分享一个数据。我是我同事 Anne DePrince 在这里进行的一项大型研究的一部分。她写了一本精彩的书，叫《每 90 秒》，讲述了特别是遭受亲密伴侣暴力的女性的经历。但 Anne 和我，我是一名创伤性脑损伤研究人员，而她是一位在亲密伴侣暴力 (IPV) 领域拥有整个职业生涯的创伤研究人员。我们联合起来研究脑损伤、创伤性脑损伤以及缺氧或勒颈相关脑损伤的频率。我们想，好吧，让我们深入研究这种现象，看看它发生的频率。在几乎 100% 的暴力关系中，女性都遭受过创伤性脑损伤。
violence in this case. How common is TBI among survivors of domestic violence? And can you tell our listeners about the work you've been doing with this population? It's so important. And Kim, what I love about the way that you're approaching this is it's the perfect segue. So listeners think, I know something about brain injury because I followed a conversation that was spearheaded by NFL wives originally and then by NFL players and their retired player unions. We've seen the documentary and we have a kind of pretty robust public discourse about brain injury, about concussion, which is mild traumatic brain injury. What people may not realize is that brain injuries are more common than that in other populations. So the risk to people in
在这种情况下发生的暴力。创伤性脑损伤（TBI）在家庭暴力幸存者中有多普遍？您能向我们的听众介绍一下您在这一群体中所做的工作吗？这非常重要。Kim，我非常喜欢您处理这个问题的方式，这是一个完美的过渡。听众们可能会想，我对脑损伤有所了解，因为我关注过最初由NFL球员妻子发起，后来由NFL球员及其退役球员联盟推动的对话。我们看过纪录片，对于脑损伤，也就是轻度创伤性脑损伤（即脑震荡），我们有相当深入的公众讨论。人们可能没有意识到的是，在其他群体中，脑损伤比这更常见。因此，对于这些人来说，风险在于
violent relationships to sustain brain injury, traumatic and anoxic from strangulation in particular, is extraordinarily high. And I'll share with you just one piece of data. I'm part of the big study here with my colleague Anne DePrince. She wrote a brilliant book. It's called Every 90 Seconds about the experience of women exposed to intimate partner violence in particular. But Anne and I, I'm a traumatic brain injury researcher and as a trauma researcher who has a whole career of working in this intimate partner violence or IPV space. And we brought our forces together to look at the frequency of brain injury, traumatic brain injury, and anoxic or strangulation-related brain injury. And we thought, well, let's drill into the phenomena and see how often it happens. in almost 100% of violent relationships, women are exposed to traumatic brain injuries.
我们想，好吧，这可能说得通。然而，我们没有准备好的是，当我们询问勒颈问题时，我已经在刑事司法环境中工作多年了。我想，好吧，我从女性那里听到了很多关于她们勒颈经历的描述，但这可能是一个低频率的基础事件。当你调查处于暴力关系中的女性时，70% 的人在最近一次家庭暴力事件中被勒过。所以这些女性脑损伤的频率确实令人震惊。我指出，我在 2018 年做过一次关于刑事司法系统中脑损伤的 TED 演讲，我指出，遭受人际暴力的女性在症状负担和损伤史上看起来就像退役的 NFL 球员，但她们没有退休福利、未决的责任赔偿、电视纪录片、公众舆论和支持。因此，在遭受暴力的人群中存在着一场令人震惊的公共卫生危机。我们才刚刚开始正视这个问题的严重性。现在，我看了你关于刑事司法系统中患有脑损伤的人的 TEDx 演讲，你引用的数字也令人震惊。你能谈谈那项工作，以及在刑罚系统中发生了什么，为什么这么多人经历脑损伤，以及正在采取什么措施来
We thought, okay, well, maybe that makes some sense. What we weren't prepared for, though, is when we asked about strangulation, I had been working for years in criminal justice settings. I thought, well, I'm hearing a lot from women about their experience with strangulation, but maybe this is a low-frequency base rate event. when you pull women who are in violent relationships, 70% of them were strangled in their most recent episode of domestic violence. So the frequency of brain injuries for these women is really stunning. I make the point, I had a 2018 TED talk about brain injuries in the criminal justice
我们当时想，好吧，这或许说得通。但我们没有准备好的是，当我们询问有关勒颈的情况时，我已经在刑事司法领域工作多年了。我原以为，我从女性那里听到了很多关于她们遭受勒颈的经历，但这可能是一个低频率的基础事件。当你调查那些处于暴力关系中的女性时，70%的人在最近一次家庭暴力事件中曾被勒颈。因此，这些女性遭受脑损伤的频率确实令人震惊。我曾指出，我在2018年的TED演讲中谈到了刑事司法系统中的脑损伤问题
system and I make the point that women exposed to interpersonal violence look like retired NFL players in terms of the burden of symptoms they have in terms of their injury history, but they don't have the benefit of retirement benefits, a pending liability settlement, a documentary on TV, public sentiment and support. So there is a really shocking public health crisis among people who exposed to violence. And we've really only just begun to make eye contact with this scope of that problem. Now, I watched that TEDx talk that you did about people in the criminal justice system with TBI and the numbers that you cited were also astounding. Can you talk about that work and what's happening in the penal system that so many people are experiencing TBI and what's being done to
帮助他们吗？我们在科罗拉多州一直在做一些这样的工作，这可能是我们的第 12 个年头了，研究脑损伤史的普遍性以及其他问题（精神疾病、药物滥用、累犯、治疗失败）的共病情况，并真正审视所有这些变量之间这种复杂的关系。我们注意到，在我们开始工作前的几十年里，几位研究人员以及从那以后更多的研究人员已经认识到，在刑事法律系统等环境中，脑损伤史的普遍性比一般人群中要高得多。我简单说一下。如果你看 CDC 的数据，所有脑损伤的人口普遍率约为 8%。这包括那种你完全康复且预计不会有任何长期不良后果风险的简单损伤。所以人们患有更严重损伤的可能性要
help them, if anything? We've been doing some of this work in Colorado for this is like our 12th year maybe looking at the prevalence of brain injury history and the comorbidity of other problems, mental illness, substance abuse, recidivism, treatment failure, and really looking at this complicated relationship between all of those variables. What we noticed, and several researchers in the decades before we started our work and more researchers since then have recognized that the prevalence of brain injury history in settings like the criminal legal system is disproportionately high than is true in the general population. And I'll just do a quick little aside. And if you look at CDC data, the population prevalence of all brain injuries is about 8%. And that includes the kind of uncomplicated injury that you recover fully from and you don't expect to have any risk for. long-term poor outcomes. So the risk of the likelihood that people have more significant injuries is
低得多，但所有损伤的比例约为 8%。当你观察监狱、社区矫正时，数字要高得多。在科罗拉多州，我们观察了这里刑事司法系统中的大约 5,000 人，所有成年人的数字是 54%。刑事司法系统中的所有人。而且它因环境而异。我们发表了很多这些数据，我知道你会分享这些链接，但重要的是，在我们的一些女性特定项目中，
much lower, but all injuries is about 8%. When you look in jails, for example, Jail's prisons, community corrections, the numbers are much higher. And in Colorado, our number across all adults, we looked at just about 5,000 people in the criminal justice system here. That number was 54%. of all people in the criminal justice system. And it varied depending on the setting. And we published a lot of these data, and I know you'll share those links, but importantly, in some of our female-specific program,
有一个是我们研究的一部分，在我们的一个法庭中有一个女性累犯项目。这是一个小组。这些女性因第二次暴力犯罪而累犯，31 名女性中，30 名有严重的脑损伤史。在刑事法律人群中，与暴力相关的脑损伤率远高于一般人群，在一般人群中该比例在 9% 到 10% 之间，而在刑事法律环境中，这占了所有损伤的 80%。
so there was a repeat female offender program in one of our courts that was part of our research study. This was a small group. These were women who had recidivated with a second violence. offense, 31 women, 30 of them, had a significant brain injury history. And the rates of violence related brain injury is much higher in a criminal legal population than in the general population where that rate is between 9 and 10 percent in criminal legal settings. That's 80 percent of all the
是的，与暴力相关的脑损伤患者的预后比其他类型的损伤（如运动相关损伤或机动车相关损伤）要差得多。我们所知道的是，那些也有脑损伤史的人往往表现出非常复杂的共病。在我们的研究中，在刑事法律系统中那些有严重脑损伤史（即中度至重度损伤）的人中，76% 有严重的药物滥用史。74% 有精神疾病、药物滥用和脑损伤的“三位一体”。100% 的人有严重的自杀意念，但大约 40%（39.4%）的人口
injuries. It is, and the outcomes for people with violence-related brain injuries are much cooler than other kinds of injuries like sport-related injuries or motor vehicle-related injuries, for example. And what we know about people who also have a brain injury history is that they tend to present with really complicated comorbidities. In our research, among people in the criminal legal system who have a significant history of brain injury, so these are more moderate to severe injuries, 76% of them have a significant history of substance abuse. 74% have that trifecta of mental illness, substance abuse, and brain injury. 100% of them had significant suicidal ideation, but about illness 40, 39.4% that population
至少尝试过一次自杀，这比一般人群高出约 39 倍。所以，作为一种临床速记，它标记了不良后果的风险。我们知道，患有脑损伤的人更有可能再次犯罪，他们释放后更有可能需要更多的服务。我们一直在科罗拉多州进行一些非常棒的规划，通过识别脑损伤、确定治疗需求并改变这种护理的交付方式来改变这种轨迹，所有治疗照常进行，然后为基于社区的资源促进进行转介，几乎每个州都可以免费为脑损伤患者提供这种服务。我们有一些非常好的数据表明
had made at least one suicide attempt, which is about 39 times higher than is true in a general population. So it's a way to, as a kind of clinical shorthand, it flags risk for poor outcomes. We know that people who have a brain injury are more likely to reoffend, they're more likely to need more services on their release. And we've been doing some really great programming here in Colorado to change that trajectory by identifying the brain injury, identifying treatment need and changing the way that kind of care is delivered, all treatment as usual, and then making referrals for community-based resource facilitation, which almost every state has available to people with brain injury at no cost. And we have some great data to suggest
你确实可以为那些重返社区的最弱势群体改变这种轨迹。所以这关乎精神疾病的治疗、药物滥用和复发支持、减少伤害，并以适应某人认知优势和劣势的方式提供所有这些策略。所以对于有记忆缺陷的人来说是重复。对于可能没有太注意的人，邀请他们复述和总结。如果他们注意力不集中，让他们背对着开着的门或窗户坐。这真的是非常非常基础的东西，但它可能解释了为什么治疗失败率如此之高，因为人们不知道有什么不同。我们在刑事法律环境中提供
that you really can change that trajectory for the most vulnerable people reentering their community. So it's about treatment for mental illness. It's substance abuse and relapse support, it's harm reduction, and it's delivering all of those strategies in a way that accommodates someone's cognitive strengths and weaknesses. So it's repetition for someone with a memory deficit. It's inviting them to paraphrase and summarize for someone who may not have been paying a lot of attention. It's seating someone facing away from an open door or window if they're inattentive. It's really, really basic stuff, but it probably accounts for why treatment failure rates are so high is people that don't know any different. We deliver
治疗时采用“一刀切”的方式。每个人都挤进房间。我们从书本上提供减少伤害课程或复发预防。我们从手册中进行 CBT 策略，我们可以做得更好。事实证明，当你稍微调整一下，你的干预措施落地并取得成功的可能性就会高得多，我们可以让人们保持更长时间的稳定。现在，我们根本没有谈论军队。
treatment in criminal legal settings as a one-size-fits-all blanket. Everybody piles into the room. We deliver harm reduction curriculum or relapse prevention from a book. We do CBT strategies from a manual, and we can do better. And it turns out that when you tweak things just a bit, then the likelihood that your interventions land and are successful is much higher, and we can keep people afloat longer. Now, we haven't talked at all about the military.
军队中脑损伤的普遍性如何？这是否得到了更好或不同的处理，因为政府和退伍军人事务部 (VA) 在治疗他们的人员方面做得相当不错？是的，VA 在这项研究中确实处于领先地位，识别脑损伤的风险，识别脑损伤与 PTSD 之间的共病。VA 在识别最容易患上 PTSD 并因脑损伤而产生并发症的人员特征方面做了很多工作，以便我们能够识别出脆弱的大脑。VA 确实在引领文化转变，消除耻辱感并改善护理获取方面发挥了作用。
What is the prevalence of TBI in the military? And is that being handled better differently because the government and the VA, they do a pretty good job of treating their people? Yeah, and the VA has really led to charge on a lot of this research, identifying the risk for brain injury, identifying the comorbidity between brain injury and PTSD, for example. The VA has gone a long way towards identifying the characteristics of people most likely to develop PTSD and have complications from TDI when they're in combat so that we can identify people with vulnerable. brains as we think about it a lot more and more. And the VA has really been responsible, this VA Department of Defense, for leading a shift in culture around stigma and access to care.
军队中创伤性脑损伤的患病率是多少？政府和退伍军人事务部（VA）在处理这个问题上是否做得更好或有所不同，因为他们对待自己的人员做得相当不错？是的，退伍军人事务部确实在许多此类研究中发挥了带头作用，确定了脑损伤的风险，并确定了脑损伤与创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）之间的共病关系。退伍军人事务部在识别最有可能在战斗中患上PTSD并出现TBI并发症的人群特征方面取得了很大进展，这样我们就可以在考虑时更多地识别出大脑脆弱的人群。退伍军人事务部和国防部确实在引领围绕污名化和医疗服务获取的文化转变方面负有责任。
What is largely true, and we see a lot of returning service personnel and retired military in our criminal legal populations too, is that there is still, for active duty folks, significant disincentive to reporting brain injury and certainly significant disincentive to reporting brain injury when the returning home from a deployment, because it delays ultimately their ability to rejoin their community and families. And there still is a culture of shake it off, and rub some dirt on it that makes it hard for people to disclose when they're really struggling. And certainly we see that in the PTSD world, and we see that with the horrifying suicide rates for our military service personnel and retired veterans. It is, I think, a really sustainable effort to destigmatize.
一个很大的事实是，我们在刑事法律人群中也看到了很多退伍军人和退役军人，对于现役军人来说，报告脑损伤仍然存在巨大的阻碍，尤其是从部署地返回家园时，因为这最终会延迟他们回归社区和家庭的能力。而且仍然存在一种“挺过去”、“忍一忍”的文化，这使得人们在真正挣扎时很难说出来。我们在创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）领域肯定看到了这一点，我们也看到了军人和退伍军人令人震惊的自杀率。我认为，去污名化是一项真正可持续的努力。
conversations about brain health and they've done that a lot on thinking of research on the gut biome and I think it just is we're approaching it from different angles that make the conversation easier both for our military service persons, their families for providers. You're not going to know if you don't ask and being willing to have that conversation. And I'll say this and I know we'll talk more about this in the realm of psychology, but a lot of people think about brain injury and think, well, that's not part of what I'm qualified to treat. And really, when someone has a history of brain injury, you're not treating the brain injury at all. You're treating all of the inflammatory side effects of the brain injury. It's mental illness, it's depression, it's depression,
关于大脑健康的对话，他们在肠道生物群系的研究方面做了很多思考，我认为我们只是从不同的角度接近它，这使得我们的军人、他们的家人和医疗服务提供者更容易进行对话。如果你不问，你就不会知道，而且要愿意进行那种对话。我会说这一点，我知道我们会在心理学领域更多地讨论这一点，但很多人想到脑损伤时会想，嗯，那不是我有资格治疗的范围。实际上，当某人有脑损伤史时，你根本不是在治疗脑损伤。你是在治疗脑损伤的所有炎症副作用。这是精神疾病，是抑郁症，是抑郁症，
It's relationship chaos. It's substance misuse. It's all of the things that we really are trained to do. And they may have cognitive consequences of their brain injury. That means we have to deliver our interventions in a way that is just slightly different than maybe our standard operating procedures, military pun intended. But with just that little change, our data suggests that it yields a tremendous pace. payoff. Well, speaking of the work of psychologists, are we doing enough to train the up-and-coming psychologists to know enough about traumatic brain injury to really treat people effectively
这是关系混乱。这是药物滥用。这是我们真正受过训练去处理的所有事情。他们可能会有脑损伤带来的认知后果。这意味着我们必须以一种与我们的标准操作程序（军语双关）略有不同的方式来提供干预措施。但只要有那一点点改变，我们的数据表明它会产生巨大的回报。那么，说到心理学家的工作，我们在培训未来的心理学家以了解足够的创伤性脑损伤知识，从而真正有效地治疗人们方面做得够吗？
when they come into their practice? Here in Colorado, this was not that long ago. Kim, I am horrified to say, I think this might have just been six years ago or so. And this is true in many states. In Colorado, there was language in our Medicaid. language that ruled someone out from receiving Medicaid-funded behavioral health services if they had a history of brain injury. So if that person had a history of brain injury, they were directed towards brain injury-related services, even though what they were presenting for and what they needed were treatment for depression, treatment for substance misuse, any manner of behavioral health services. And Annamoribas fought really hard with the Hickpuff team here in Colorado to change that
当他们进入诊所时？在科罗拉多州，这没过多久。金，我很震惊地说，我想这可能才六年前左右。这在许多州都是事实。在科罗拉多州，我们的医疗补助计划中曾有条款，规定如果某人有脑损伤史，就不能接受医疗补助资助的行为健康服务。因此，如果那个人有脑损伤史，他们会被引导去接受与脑损伤相关的服务，即使他们表现出的症状和他们真正需要的是抑郁症治疗、药物滥用治疗或任何形式的行为健康服务。安娜·莫里巴斯（Annamoribas）与科罗拉多州的Hickpuff团队进行了艰苦的斗争，以改变那项
law. Because that law was on the books for so long here and is still on the books in many states, there is still a prevailing kind of headwind among behavioral health professionals that brain injury means something separate. Like, oh, I had no idea that you had a history of brain injury. I need to send you to someone who specializes in brain injury. And the truth is, this person needs someone who specializes in the treatment of grief or in the treatment of adjustment disorder. Those things are really paramount. And certainly the priority at that time to reduce the risk of really catastrophic outcomes for this person, brain injury or not. So just to wrap up, what's next on your research docket?
法律。因为那项法律在这里实施了太久，而且在许多州仍然有效，行为健康专业人员中仍然存在一种普遍的阻力，认为脑损伤意味着某种独立的东西。比如，“哦，我不知道你有脑损伤史。我需要把你送到专门研究脑损伤的人那里。”事实是，这个人需要的是专门治疗悲伤或调整障碍的人。这些事情才是真正最重要的。当然，当时的优先事项是降低这个人发生灾难性后果的风险，无论是否有脑损伤。那么总结一下，你的研究计划下一步是什么？
What are you working on now? What are the questions you still want to answer? We're really excited to support lots of people doing great work. There's a team, Pennsylvania and New York, who are looking at a really great double-blind, placebo-controlled study of brain injury resource facilitation. in a maximum security men's prison. We have a pilot program here going in women's prison, and we have two really exciting, entirely stakeholder-led pieces of legislation in the last few years,
你现在在做什么？你还想回答什么问题？我们非常高兴支持许多做着出色工作的人。有一个团队，在宾夕法尼亚州和纽约州，他们正在进行一项非常棒的关于脑损伤资源促进的双盲、安慰剂对照研究，地点是在一个最高安全级别的男子监狱。我们这里有一个在女子监狱进行的试点项目，在过去几年里，我们有两个非常令人兴奋、完全由利益相关者主导的立法项目，
one to screen everyone a Department of Corrections for brain injury, the other woman who had a history of violent relationships who wanted to be sure that no one went through what she did, so her bill is to screen all victims of violent crime for brain injury. And that's really a game-changer. because then we could deliver care aimed at treating the actual brain injury, not all of the fallout of the brain injury. What is exciting, though, on that stakeholder side is to see the ways that this conversation is changing the way stakeholders talk about themselves and what they want from providers and their expectations for care. And this is true on the VA side and among military and service personnel.
一个是筛查惩教署的每个人是否有脑损伤，另一个是一位有暴力关系史的女性，她想确保没有人经历过她所经历的事情，所以她的法案是筛查所有暴力犯罪受害者是否有脑损伤。这确实是一个改变游戏规则的举措。因为这样我们就可以提供旨在治疗实际脑损伤的护理，而不是治疗脑损伤的所有后果。然而，在利益相关者方面令人兴奋的是，看到这种对话正在改变利益相关者谈论他们自己、他们对服务提供者的要求以及他们对护理的期望的方式。这在退伍军人事务部（VA）方面以及军人和服役人员中也是如此。
It's true for us in criminal justice. And it is really exciting to see communities talking about brain health in ways that are empowering and destigmatizing. I've got a colleague here in Colorado. His work is in a new book by my colleague Annie Leontas is called Sex with a Brain Injury, the best ever first person account of recovery from a brain injury that has a really adept through line with historical figures from Harriet Tubman and all the presidents whose names you'll recognize. In any case, this colleague of mine here in Colorado has really started a horror community revolution. What he found is that by talking about brain health and history of brain
这对我们刑事司法领域的人来说也是如此。看到社区以赋权和去污名化的方式谈论大脑健康，这真的很令人兴奋。我在科罗拉多州有一位同事。他的工作被我的同事安妮·莱昂塔斯（Annie Leontas）写进了一本新书，书名是《脑损伤后的性生活》，这是有史以来关于脑损伤康复最好的第一人称叙述，书中有一条非常巧妙的线索，贯穿了从哈里特·塔布曼（Harriet Tubman）到你耳熟能详的所有总统等历史人物。无论如何，我在科罗拉多州的这位同事确实发起了一场社区革命。他发现，通过谈论大脑健康和脑损伤史，
injury, it was a way to address unmet need for treatment for mental illness and treatment for historical trauma. And it was less shaming. And it's gotten community members to the table. And we've deployed counselors to neighborhoods that have been understandably mistrustful of psychology. And it's really been a beautiful thing to see people take ownership of brain health and to recognize how high those stakes are. And we realize also that untreated brain injury. makes inflammation worse and untreated mental illness can also aggravate inflammation. And, you know, in that way, it's a really destructive cycle. So I've been really proud to see stakeholders intervene to Tobigar in ways that psychology maybe has fallen short, and we could
这是一种解决精神疾病治疗和历史创伤治疗未满足需求的方法。而且这种方式带来的羞耻感更少。它让社区成员参与了进来。我们已经向那些对心理学有理所当然的不信任感的社区派遣了咨询师。看到人们开始掌控自己的大脑健康并认识到这些风险有多高，这真是一件美好的事情。我们也意识到，未经治疗的脑损伤会加重炎症，而未经治疗的精神疾病也会加重炎症。而且，你知道，从这个意义上说，这是一个非常具有破坏性的循环。所以我很自豪地看到利益相关者以心理学可能做得不足的方式进行干预，我们可以
learn a lot from them. Well, Dr. Gorgans, this has been really interesting. I want to thank you for spending time with me today. Kim, this has been a highlight. I so appreciate you. And thanks for the invite and if people need any more info or I can be helpful, they can find me here at the University of Denver. They can find me at APA. And I just really appreciate the airtime. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
从他们身上学到很多。好的，戈根斯博士，这真的非常有趣。我要感谢你今天花时间和我在一起。金，这是一个亮点。我非常感谢你。感谢你的邀请，如果人们需要更多信息或者我能提供帮助，他们可以在丹佛大学找到我。他们可以在美国心理学会（APA）找到我。我非常感谢这段播出时间。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。